okay uh
do i look smaller in the face do i look
like i'm losing weight i feel like i am
i feel good okay we're gonna do a
reaction to the miss marvel trailer
because
i'm really curious to see like i've
heard people say they changed their
powers i don't know if that's really
true or not but we're gonna check it out
and we're gonna see what's going on okay
oh that's cool
[Music]
i like the speech bubbles the animation
okay so first off i just want to say
i get it
you get what
high school
kamala kamala another adventure shirt
cute she thinks i'm some kind of weirdo
you were a weirdo boys excuse me yeah
you're kind of on my shirt sorry
but you're staring at the window in your
little fantasy land i love the santa
claus
kamala hey already really come on like
do i have to figure out my whole future
before launchers
[Music]
maybe they're right
i spend too much time
and fantasyland
that is not to
it's you really the brown girls from
jersey city
you say well this reminds me of the
college so much
that's a fantasy too
are those quantum games
no way those are quantities something
happened to you no why did you hear
something come on
what does it feel like
cosmic
[Music]
i always thought i wanted this kind of
life
but i never imagined any of this
do you know what you are
so they're here
i'm a superhero
[Music]
okay
that trailer looks fine as hell it looks
exactly like the like the kamala khan
comic right here's the thing those guys
who aren't familiar with this and we
have a video coming out later on today
although this reaction video is probably
going to get a copyright claim because
of the soundtrack but uh we have a video
coming out later on today on comics
explained which will basically give you
the whole publication history of kamala
khan uh this feels exactly like that
those look like quantum bands i don't
know if they are the quantum bands if
they are the quantum bands that's
amazing but i can see how people said
that they basically changed their powers
so i imagine the first thing people are
going to wonder is like what is her
connection to carol danvers because
obviously the way in which he uses her
powers looks almost identical to like
the power type that carol danvers has if
those are not the quantum bands those
are likely the mega bands which is
entirely possible too right it's one of
those two things but regardless right
those are basically cosmic
cosmic-powered bands so for those of you
guys who aren't really familiar with
kamala khan and we'll talk more about
this as we go through with the comments
explain video that explains your
character and carol danvers was really
really popular in the 70s and then in
like the late 80s and 90s and the early
2000s she was just the hot girl with big
boobs on the avengers that's all she was
that's literally all she was and it's
all she was ever known for she was just
hugely irrelevant
move to 2014 and kelly sue deconnick's
story captain marvel volume one higher
faster further more this was a comic
that basically moved carol danvers away
from being miss marvel and becoming
captain marvel and she actually ended up
taking that mantle which she was really
kind of told she should do it by captain
america but she used that mantle which
had originally been used by marvel of
the cree and it made good sense because
carol danvers basically got her powers
from a wishing machine called the psych
magnetron and wished that she had the
powers of mar-vell and then she became
miss marvel right basically other people
had the mantle of captain marvel before
her but that's when she initially took
it over what this meant is that the
title of miss marvel was basically
vacant in marvel comics at the time now
go into a story
going to jonathan hickman's avengers new
avengers oh my god i love jonathan
hickman new avengers here's the reason
why i bring it up all the time every
major thing that happened in marvel
comics between like 2013 and 2015 really
2012 and 2015 happened because of this
comic but basically in this story there
was kind of a mini story inside of it
called infinity and the long and short
of it is that thanos showed up on earth
looking for his son he got into a fight
with blackpool who was a leader of the
inhumans and black bolt detonated the
terrigen bomb what this meant is that
the terrigen mist started spreading
throughout the world so anybody in the
world who was an inhuman and didn't know
it when they were exposed to the mist
they would go into a cocoon they would
have these existential visions and then
they would come out with powers with no
other clue what form those powers would
take that's what happened to kamala khan
she was a young girl a pakistani
american girl living in new jersey who
idolized captain america and iron man
but carol danvers captain marvel more
than anybody else and the result of this
is that when she was exposed to the
territories and she went into her cocoon
she basically came out with what were in
effect the powers of reed richards from
the fantastic four um i imagine the
reason why they switched her powers
around so they're not really a result of
her modifying her own molecular
structure and instead our energy-based
powers is probably two-fold one so they
can bring her closer in line with like
the marvels so like monica rambo carol
danvers that kind of thing so they all
kind of share a singular thing otherwise
if it wasn't for that she would only
really be related to the nature of the
marvels in terms of like just the nature
of of her name right but when you look
at how monica rambo uses her powers when
you look at the the power set of carol
danvers when you look at the powers of
miss marvel or of kamala khan they're
all basically the same power source or
they look like the same power source we
know monica got her powers because of
wanda and wandavision but they all seem
to manifest in terms of like this same
physical appearance and that's one of
the reasons why a lot of people are
saying that like in doctor strange too
that person that we see uh basically
looks like some variation of monica
rambo or possibly even blue marvel
because their power the the look of
their appearance the energy they give
off their vibe basically looks the exact
same as like carol danvers right so
regardless i imagine that's probably why
they changed it not a bad thing right
because even if they are not necessarily
even that's not the case inner powers
are tied to like the nega bands or the
quantum bands two of the most powerful
artifacts that exist in the entirety of
marvel comics it would be cool man
because that means now we're going into
space say for example that it is the
quantum manager the nega bands now
you're looking at things like quasar
you're looking at like the potential
introduction of phi level who i have
been screaming about forever phila vel
is so cool phyla vel's one of those
girls you do not
start
with philabel
wobe tied the poor soul that runs up on
file available wanting to start some
business right like she'll
should take you for a ride on the pain
train phyla vel is amazing i absolutely
love her character but i imagine they're
just tied more into like cosmic energies
cosmic capabilities which just makes
good sense because the marvel cinematic
universe is focusing more on the cosmos
than they are simply just earth in the
mcu having said that i'm excited for it
right i mean here's the thing kamala
khan stories were always fun there was
never really a time when she was
disinteresting or boring or anything
like that they were always a good time
but i prefer to read stories about about
uh teenagers as superheroes i find it's
just so fun because the stories don't
usually involve like overly dark tones
like they do with adult superheroes
right like punisher max or like superior
spider-man or something like that
teenagers are usually written in just a
really fun way so what's just going on
like this fun adventure a really good
example of strange academy right like
dormammu's son is in strange academy and
i don't even know how he had one i don't
even think it's been explained in
strange academy yet maybe it is and i
just missed it but whatever like it's
basically like the hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry led by doctor
strange and like jericho drum and
scarlet witch and like a whole bunch of
people just teaching kids how to use
magic it's like the most fun ever so i
feel like this this show is gonna be
great because here's the thing i think
it's gonna really really just tie in for
a lot of young women out there right for
a lot of young girls who are looking for
something they can identify with right
something they can kind of relate to
because a lot of young girls are
teenagers and they go through all the
teenage girls stuff and i feel like
we're going to see all of that in the
kamala khan show boys and she wants to
ask him out but she's afraid of being
rejected so she's just going to sit on
you know rest on her laurels and wait
for him to make the first move whatever
the case is right just all the things
that young people go through so again
i'm really excited to see the show i
feel like it's just gonna be fun just
gonna be a good fun show having said
that i don't really imagine this show is
gonna have much in the way of twists and
turns like one division or loki or
anything like that if anything i think
it'll be pretty straightforward i think
it'll be very similar to like hawkeye or
falcon in the winter soldier where the
success of the show really comes more by
way of easter eggs and references as
opposed to like coming out of nowhere
surprises having said that it is the mcu
and we won't know until the show comes
out so with that being said guys let me
know down in the comments section what
you think about the trailer did you love
it did you hate it were you kind of like
it's okay let me know what you guys
think thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace